you just turned 50 yeah which is hard to
believe yeah there's such a youthful guy
I know remembering now that you did you
appeared on our show as a stand-up yeah
like 16 years ago yeah on a late-night
show yeah like 2000 2001 mm-hmm and if
the first time I was ever on TV was on
your show and I remember the first
commercial break the first thing you
said to me was like how old are you I
remember thinking you were very young
yeah yeah extremely young yeah what you
were you were young guy you know sure
but I have a picture for me because this
really takes me back that was a fake
safety instruction teaching people how
to be safe on the street I remember that
was your comedy was very funny thank you
you've gone on to so many bigger and
better things I congratulate you thank
you very much how did you celebrate your
birthday you just turned 50 what did you
do I did a party at the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery it's this beautiful
Cemetery and I had this incredible party
all my friends were there and they got
me as a present as a surprise grave they
got me a grave wait your friends chipped
in and bought you a real grave yes you
have a plot I have a Fred Armisen have a
plot yeah right near Johnny Ramone
nika's Linda Ramone his widow yeah just
arranged it and it was a real surprise I
had no idea was coming and that's what
they got me wait that is so strange to
look at your that's such a strange thing
because now are you really gonna use
this plot is it going to be your plot oh
definitely you know in a way it's are
you gonna go visit me well no I'll go
away before you
oh yeah or we can go together that's the
sweetest proposal of the suicide pact we
could go together it was a really nice
surprise it was really it's just a very
cool place it's a very they have a lot
of events that we have for those of you
live in Los Angeles yeah they show
movies there over the summer and sides
it's really cool you seem very and I
like this a lot of people especially in
this industry and in our society who
were worried about getting older you
seem very comfortable about getting
older yeah I think there's a way to do
it in a sort of cool way and to have
some dignity and to look nice and it's
also I don't have a choice really I mean
like I could try to fight it or I could
try to embrace it and but so many people
in this town fight it and they get
radical crazy surgeries I'm going to be
doing all of this very soon I'm having
everything from the waist up so lost
cause the waist down but the waist up
I'm gonna have everything completely
radically changed I'm just gonna go for
it why not rather than age gracefully
I'm gonna fight it every step of
immediately yeah I'm just gonna do my
hands when you die they look like baby
hands yeah I'm not gonna name names but
there are it is something I've noticed
over the years you probably noticed a to
Andi where people come on the show and
it's people who have had all this work
done yeah they look but your hands give
you away yeah and they don't and and
there's nothing you can do about that so
I'll be talking to them and they'll look
really look like they're about 25 years
old and then they'll go like this but
anyway
looks like they're being strangled by a
zombie
you